the price of policy misstep
the price of poor communication of
policy intentions
is very high
this week we have an opportunity
to work towards
minimizing the risks of missteps and
poor communication
let me give you a few highlights
in this context of us appealing to
policy makers
to act with the sense of
urgency now and also to act together
we see very clear areas where we can do
better
even in this more complex environment
first
bring inflation down
we know that Rising interest rates come
at some cost to growth but we also know
that not tightening enough
to put the lease on inflation
would mean interest rates
staying higher for longer resulting in
even more harm to growth and to people
for central banks this means taking
decisive action when it is necessary but
also it means communicating as clearly
as they can
second
act now to put in place responsible
fiscal policy
we must prioritize protecting the
vulnerable the vulnerable households the
vulnerable businesses that are
so important for the economy to function
but we have to do that with uh fiscal
buffers exhausted because of the
pandemic levels of debt very high and so
the the obvious conclusion is that
policy measures need to be well targeted
and they need to be temporary
steer away from across the board fiscal
support
that is neither effective nor affordable
if we are to help
people and fight inflation we must
ensure that fiscal and monetary policy
go hand in hand
you heard me
saying that multiple times I'm going to
say it again because it is so important
for this message
to penetrate when monetary policy puts a
foot on the brakes
fiscal policy should not step on the
accelerator because if it does we are
for a very dangerous right
and third we need to act now to
safeguard Financial stability
particularly as we see Rising financial
sector risks macro Prudential policies
need to be even more Vigilant and
address proactively pockets of
vulnerability
in this environment we also must support
vulnerable emerging and market and
developing countries it is tough for
everybody but it is even tougher for
countries that are now being hit by a
stronger dollar High borrowing costs
capital outflows a triple blow that is
particularly heavy for countries that
are on the high level of debt